Tom one of your scripts that you had
back in from the 2006 era on ended up
getting you a manager is that right
mm-hmm that was in a I think 2012 so it
was a few years into making stuff the
the way I got the managers well I
probably rewind a little bit I went to
USC you know in film school any film
school you meet a lot of people make a
lot of friends and they're kind of like
the ones that help you make stuff once
you're out of school that gets you jobs
and that also connect you so in 2012 I
was with a writer and a producer friend
we were working on this script for it a
teen conspiracy thriller that took place
in Napa and while that was being written
I was then kind of producing like a fake
trailer to help pitch it to help show
what this movie would look and feel like
and I said we it was half half of it no
not have I probably a quarter of it was
like a so-called script o matic
so we were just like yous we would rip
shots from existing movies and then the
other 70% we would actually shoot so we
you know got locations hired actors we
wrote the script for a trailer and yeah
we went out shot those elements and then
cut it all together color time that so
it looks all very consistent had a mixed
at a friend's post-production house and
so we had a trailer that looked a lot of
people were confused they thought it was
this was a movie that had already gotten
made also a one of the actresses in the
movie was Aimee Teegarden who before she
became well-known actress she was
actually the lead actress in my thesis
film at USC so that's how she and I met
became friends so she agreed to be in
this trailer just because people
recognize her
so when the trailer was saying out you
know we got a little bit more attention
than we would if it was just if she
wasn't in it and then yeah so one of my
friends from USC was friends with a
manager he sent this manager trailer
they're like yeah this looks like
something we can get made and that's how
that's how I got my first my first
managers and that's actually also how I
met the writer who wrote danger once
Stefan because they were managing him at
the same time too so even though that
teen conspiracy fool and never got made
it eventually led to danger one getting
made just because it introduced Stefan
and I and we became friends and realized
you know we work together well
you